à brosses montceau au fin fond de la
seine et marne ce restaurant accueille
chaque jour une centaine de couverts à
plus de 90 km de paris c'est le dernier
relais routier avant l'autoroute a6
l'occasion pour les chauffeurs
d'effectuer une dernière pose de
conduites réglementaire la plupart du
temps les autres stations service sont
complètes
il y à beaucoup de monde ici la
nourriture est bonne on peut se doucher
pour nous c'est mieux de s'arrêter là un
parking gratuit pour le moment le
restaurant a reçu une lettre leur
imposant de payer près de cinquante
trois mille euros de taxes pour cette
aire de stationnement
une somme qui servirait à financer le
grand paris les propriétaires refusent
de payer somme à 500 mètres de lianes et
franchement là on a pas de transports en
commun on n'a pas le métro on s'en fiche
quoi le grand paris ça vient pas
jusqu'ici on ne peut pas mettre le
parking payant que j'aurai plus de
chauffeurs ne peuvent pas se permettre
de payer le parking on paye déjà sur la
taxe foncière
c'est déjà dans la foncière alors une
taxe sur les taxes ras-le-bol quoi une
taxe qui s'applique aux parkings ayant
une superficie supérieure à 500 mètres
carrés
celui là en fait 6800 et les chauffeurs
l'assurent ils ne s'arrêteront plus il
devient payant c'est qu'on se retrouve
avec un parking à 10 euros par paquet 1
0 20 euro ça fait trente euros le repas
ça fait
on pourra pas quoi et vous arrêterez ou
son bord de la route sur un petit sur
les petits chemins ou quoi que ce soit
pour essayer de faire ma coupure
la famille a rendez vous le 10 mai
prochain avec les services des impôts
pour trouver des solutions